no
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález el conflicto
en colombia según datos del centro
nacional de memoria histórica ha dejado
hasta ahora unas 262 mil personas
muertas 80 mil desaparecidos 8 millones
de personas desplazadas y unos 37 mil
secuestrados todo esto entre 1958 y el
2016 muchos de estos casos fueron
causados por la antigua guerrilla de las
farc este grupo guerrillero hizo del
secuestro un arma de guerra y su fuente
de financiación
recientemente la jurisdicción especial
para la paz conocida como gp que es un
mecanismo de justicia pactado en el
acuerdo de paz de la habana imputó a
ocho ex combatientes de alto rango de
este antiguo grupo guerrillero por
crímenes de guerra y de lesa humanidad
por los secuestros que realizaron y todo
lo que esto conlleva para ampliar este
tema hemos invitado al señor eduardo
cifuentes muñoz él es presidente de la
gp a quien saludamos en la ciudad de
bogotá señor cifuentes gracias por estar
con nosotros y como fue este proceso
para llegar a esta acusación contra
estos 8
desde la antigua guerrilla de las farc
en colombia
bien la sala de reconocimiento de la
jurisdicción especial para la paz como
sala de justicia desde la competencia de
abrir macroprocesos la jefe se ocupa de
delitos del sistema son delitos que
agrupan miles de hechos delictivos y
muchas víctimas este macroproceso se
denominó el del principio las
retenciones ilegales por las farc a
partir de un informe comprensivo de la
fiscalía general general de la nación le
correspondió a la sala de reconocimiento
recaudar mucha información practicar
pruebas leer los expedientes de la
fiscalía las sentencias judiciales
recibir muchos informes de víctimas
narrativas de las víctimas cruzar muchos
bancos de datos sobre el secuestro de
diferentes organizaciones y con base en
esto establecer la existencia de
patrones de prácticas y de políticas en
este caso por parte de los miembros del
exceso variado de las farc
y así pudo efectivamente constatar como
lo dice esta providencia judicial que
para los efectos de financiación de las
acciones armadas de este grupo
subversivo e igualmente para los efectos
de control territorial y para sus
estrategias de liberar presos de las
farc en las cárceles de colombia acudió
a prácticas sistemáticas de ataques de
la población civil crece pudieron
traducir en el lenguaje del derecho
internacional humanitario' del derecho
penal internacional y el estatuto de
roma en toma de redes y otras graves
privaciones de la libertad otan la
comisión de delitos de lesa humanidad
con base en esto esta providencia hace
imputaciones a los máximos responsables
que son justamente los miembros del ex
secretario de las farc
señor cifuentes ya está hecha la
acusación que sigue entonces en este
proceso legal para los acusados
de por vida con el trámite ante la jec
los acusados tienen 30 días hábiles para
los efectos de reconocer plenamente su
responsabilidad si hay reconocimiento de
responsabilidad entonces se abre la
posibilidad de que se convoque a una
audiencia formal frente a las víctimas
de reconocimiento de esta
responsabilidad en ese caso ellos
podrían recibir sanciones propias que
son sanciones que restringen la libertad
y que obligan las reparaciones para las
víctimas en el caso de que no reconozcan
responsabilidad las haga reconocimiento
entonces notificará a la unidad de
investigación y acusación de la propia
jurisdicción especial para la paz para
que ésta ante una sección del mismo
tribunal para la paz
y una acusación en ese evento se sigue
un proceso judicial con todas las
garantías correspondientes y si se
encuentran culpables y responsables pues
podrán ser sancionados con penas de
prisión hasta de 20 años señor cifuentes
y qué pasará entonces con el recorrido
político que tienen ya estos 8
integrantes del hoy en día partido farc
seguirán en sus escaños en el congreso
colombiano
en la participación política es muy
amplia la conformación de partidos
políticos la intervención en diferentes
escenarios políticos la elección para
cargos de elección popular en el caso de
los ex guerrilleros de las farc ex
miembro del secretariado que ocupan
curules en el senado de la república le
corresponderá precisamente a la sección
del tribunal para la paz que dictará la
sentencia correspondiente estimar si la
sanción propia que supone restricción de
la libertad limitación de la libertad y
al mismo tiempo tarea de reparación en
favor de las víctimas es o no compatible
el trabajo legislativo se tratará pues
de una determinación que en un momento
posterior debe adoptar la elección del
tribunal para la paz todavía nosotros no
podemos en este momento del proceso
anticipar cuál puede hacer el efecto de
esa determinación pero en todo caso la
participación en política es muy amplia
la razón de ser del acuerdo de paz en
cierta medida significó dejar las armas
para que precisamente estas exigencias o
reivindicaciones de cambio de las farc
pudiesen hacerse a través de la
democracia la única forma no es no es la
participación como promocionador es la
única participación
previsible pueden ser muchas sin embargo
repito esta determinación sobre si es o
no compatible ser senador con al mismo
tiempo tener que ejecutar una sanción
propia le cabe adoptar a la sección del
tribunal para la paz y de un momento
posterior tener cifuentes hay sectores
que critican que lage ha tomado mucho
tiempo para llegar a dar este tipo de
resultados eso le ha valido también
señalamientos en colombia por parte de
ciudadanos y también de diferentes
sectores políticos que dice usted al
respecto
de ninguna manera yo creo que por el
contrario en un tiempo récord dos años y
medio se está que realmente llegando a
un punto en el que se contrasta mucha
información se decretan prueba se
sistematiza un material se conocen
hechos que no se conocían en el pasado
estamos hablando de miles de víctimas
este es un macroproceso que implica
macro victimización y conjuntamente con
este macroproceso también la sala de
conocimiento está gestionando y abriendo
y está cumpliendo y desarrollando otros
macroprocesos muy importantes de suerte
que aquí hay un trabajo arduo de la
jurisdicción yo creo que en un tiempo
muy acotado acotado precisamente se está
respondiendo ante el país como nunca
antes cerca del 80 por ciento de los
secuestros en colombia en este caso
llevaron a la impunidad esta es la
primera vez en la que efectivamente se
hace una invitación a los máximos
responsables
políticas y acciones que en el contexto
del conflicto armado interno atacaron de
manera masiva a la población civil y que
efectivamente produjeron esos graves
delitos como la toma de rehenes y
privaciones graves de la libertad y
señor cifuentes usted que le dice a esos
diferentes sectores políticos en
colombia que dicen que esta jurisdicción
especial para la paz es un mecanismo de
impunidad que fue pactado en la habana
entre el gobierno de ese entonces en
colombia y la guerrilla de las farc
no es un mecanismo de impunidad porque
precisamente busca la verdad la verdad
el derecho a la verdad es un derecho de
las víctimas si no hay verdad
efectivamente impunidad de todas maneras
los que reconocen verdad también tienen
en este caso
un trámite que les lleva necesariamente
a recibir una sanción
la sanción propia pasiones que
eventualmente van a ser supervisadas
inclusive por naciones unidas y de otro
lado los que no reconocen la verdad y
asumen la responsabilidad les pueden
recibir sanciones de prisión hasta de 20
años eso es todo menos impunidad de otro
lado es importante destacar aquí que se
busca también aparte de la justicia la
reconciliación y por consiguiente
debemos nosotros señalar que es muy
positivo que sean los propios entes que
requieran de las farc y en este caso
exmiembros de la cúpula que
efectivamente también a través de
versiones libres han reconocido ha
reconocido verdad y naturalmente vamos a
esperar en 30 días cuál es la respuesta
de los miembros del secretariado frente
a estas imputaciones el reconocimiento
de verdad la reparación de las víctimas
estas son sanciones selectivas muy
importantes y esto efectivamente
significa que se acordó la paz pero una
paz sin impunidad y efectivamente la que
le ha demostrado al país en un tiempo
muy breve que ha dictado providencias
judiciales que buscan definitivamente
ponerle fin a la impunidad señor
cifuentes sea cual sea el rumbo que tome
este caso qué significa para los
colombianos este anuncio que han hecho
ustedes para el conflicto colombiano y
también para la historia de este país
los crímenes de guerra cometidos por ex
guerrilleros de las farc por miembros de
la fuerza pública y por terceros deben
ser investigados juzgados y sancionados
a través precisamente de los mecanismos
establecidos en la constitución en la
ley y eso es lo que hace la jurisdicción
especial para la paz al hacerlo yo creo
que se está cimentando la paz se están
estableciendo las bases para que no se
repitan estos ciclos de violencia la
impunidad es un impulsor precisamente de
la degradación de un conflicto y de su
repetición indefinida creemos que la
respuesta que se da a través de la gp
contribuye de manera decisiva a
estabilizar los logros de la paz hacer
que las nuevas generaciones puedan
efectivamente vivir en un país con paz
esta verdad del conflicto armado interno
es importante desvelar la todas las
víctimas en colombia 9 millones de
víctimas tienen que saber qué fue lo que
pasó precisamente para no volver
a incurrir en los mismos hechos
precisamente para que los colombianos y
las colombianas asuman una lección
histórica esto no se puede repetir y por
eso el capítulo judicial que ha
inaugurado la gente es sustancial en el
sentido de que tenemos que dar un paso
hacia adelante una sociedad pacífica una
sociedad que se reconcilia consigo misma
por eso es muy importante que sean
precisamente los propios perpetradores
los que tengan la oportunidad también de
decirle al país a la sociedad las
víctimas lo que pasó lo que hicieron y
acepten la correspondiente
responsabilidad y si no lo hacen pues
serán sancionados con penas de hasta de
20 años de prisión
estamos pues poniéndole fin a la
impunidad porque estamos dándole una
oportunidad preciosa a la verdad y a la
reconciliación no solamente a la
justicia retributiva sino también a la
justicia restaurativa lo que significa
reparación de las víctimas
permitimos precisamente que los
perpetradores que dejan las armas ahora
también
entreguen la verdad y al hacerlo se
reconcilien cuando el país es una
oportunidad histórica precisamente para
los ex guerrilleros de las farc de
volver a asumir una plena civilidad y
ser los ciudadanos de este país
señor eduardo cifuentes muñoz presidente
de la jurisdicción especial para la paz
en colombia muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros en france 24 ya
ustedes también muchas gracias por
habernos acompañado siga con nuestra
programación
[Música]